hey everyone persia here and i've
rounded up more clips of the week but
this time
for valorant to celebrate its one year
anniversary
except this time we are going to add a
little twist
can you find out which one is going to
be an ace and which one is it
go ahead and leave a comment below to
let us know how many you got right and
of course
leave that like and subscribe if you
want to submit your own clips for a
future episode
then stay tuned to the end of the video
to find out how let's start you guys off
with an easy one
dude the game literally
it is nitric here alone he's got a
frenzy and a smoke in his face
oh the cage it covers himself up but
none of these players are touching it
but
nitro comes out of the cage
he's doing just fine
oh my god there's such a high flash
one dice that's it for 100. one enemy
remaining
under understand
[Music]
now
[Music]
okay was he under
i don't know i don't know on the map
that's too fast
one down
you will not kill my ally here with my
copy
30 seconds left
[Music]
one enemy remaining
spike down
one enemy remains
freedom
[Music]
you will not be killed by allies
come on kill
[Music]
foreign
he's right there
[Music]
default
three one enemy remaining
[Music]
30 seconds left jesus man
blocking site
one enemy remaining
see ya ten seconds left
[Music]
[Music]
those are our valerian clips of the week
but if you want to submit your very own
clip for a future episode
then all you have to do is tag me and
gamespot on twitter
you can find those usernames right down
below but next week if you want an idea
of what we're going to be featuring then
i'll just tell you we're going to be
featuring apex so if you have a clip or
two that
might be better than mine feel free to
send them my way because i want to check
them out and i want to make an awesome
compilation
for next time thanks for watching and
we'll see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]